على Drive-In الخاص بك ، تسقط في هذا
الوادي
وهناك فقط هذه الأبراج من
الحجر الرملي التي تنبثق من
الأرض
مرحبًا بك في Valley of Fire State Park ،
نحن على بعد حوالي ساعة شمال لاس فيجاس
وأنت لا ترى تشكيلات
في أي مكان مثل  هذا في ولاية نيفادا ، يمكنك
التسلق في جميع أنحاء الحجر الرملي لدينا
نقوش صخرية من أجداد شعب أناستازيا
لدينا مناظر مذهلة للحياة البرية لا تصدق
معظم مناظر المشي لمسافات طويلة
ستكون معظم وجهات نظرنا بعيدًا عن
الطريق ،
وهناك عدد قليل من الجولات إلى
الأجزاء الشمالية من منطقتنا  المتنزه الذي يمثل منظورًا مختلفًا
[موسيقى]
ptvs أو utvs فإن الممر الذي نسير فيه هو
مجرد أكثر المناظر المدهشة في جميع
أنحاء متنزه الولاية بأكمله الذي نمر به عبر
الوديان عبر جبال Sandstone
التي تحيط بنا جميعًا ولدينا
الكثبان الرملية الشهيرة هناك
تحصل على RPMs تذهب إلى الرمل
يركل في كل مكان الإطارات التي
تقضي فيها الشركات الضاربة وقتًا رائعًا
إنها تجربة ضخ قلب جيدة